القيادة هنا حصلنا على هذه
الأخبار المذهلة أه من مسؤولي الإطفاء
الذين كانوا يستجيبون هنا حوالي
900 أو نحو ذلك من رجال الشرطة ورجال الإطفاء هنا
في مكان الحادث والأخبار
سيئة بقدر ما كنا
نتخيلها أمشي  الأشخاص السابقون في
أزياء الهالوين على الهاتف
ينتحبون تمامًا أه يتصلون
بأفراد أسرهم لإعلامهم
بأنهم بخير ، يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك
نقالات هنا أه في انتظار لمعرفة ما إذا كان
هناك المزيد من الأشخاص الذين يحتاجون إلى
اصطحابهم إلى  مستشفى ولكن مقاطع الفيديو
التي ظهرت على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
جنبًا إلى جنب مع تنبيهات الطوارئ ،
علمنا أن شيئًا
فظيعًا قد حدث هنا ، وهذا
لتهيئة المشهد لك فريد هذا
هو إي تايوان ، هل من الممكن أن تذهب
هنا سي إن إن  فقط من هنا ، شكرًا لك ،
هذا هو حي الملهى الليلي e-
taiwan um في سيول ، إنه رمز مميز لأم من
بين العطلات الرئيسية الأخرى ، حيث
يسافر الناس من جميع أنحاء المنطقة
هنا في آسيا للمشاركة  أنا هنا
للاحتفال بعيد الهالوين في تايوان ، تعال إلى
هنا تشارلي إذا كان بإمكاننا فقط أن نرى آه ،
أريد فقط أن آخذك إلى أسفل هذا الصف من
سيارات الطوارئ هنا
، ويمكنك رؤية هذا الخط من
النقالات ، لذا فإن جميع الفنادق في
هذه المنطقة  تم بيعه بالكامل وكان
في الواقع في فندق هاميلتون
أه هنا أه إلى يساري ،
عفواً أه كان هناك
حفلة هالوين ويبدو أن
نوعًا من الحادث وقع في الناس أه
سقطوا أه يوصفون في
وسائل الإعلام المحلية بأنه  تدافع أه لكن الناس
تحطموا بشكل أساسي سقطوا
هيا لنقترب أكثر هنا أه
وتسابق الناس في الشارع
هنا الكثير من الشوارع مكتظة للغاية
وكان هناك عشرات
الآلاف من الناس هنا
وأه مقاطع الفيديو على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي  الإعلام أظهر
أشخاصا في زي ملقى على الأرض
لا يتحركون أه أصبت بنوبة قلبية